the government's new coronavirus
guidelines which allow close family
members to visit dying relatives at nick
mention them just there well they will
be welcomed by many but sadly they came
too late for those who've already lost
loved ones to the virus and found
themselves unable to say goodbye in
person Alex um died in hospital at the
age of 71 after contracting corvid 19
his family found a way to connect with
him during his last days via video calls
we're joined now by Alex's son Sebastian
um who's a consultant paediatrician
himself Sebastian thank you so much for
joining us as you and your family are I
imagine still still getting to grips
with the loss of your father
tell us a little bit about the man thank
you very much for inviting me on today
Alex was a big character is very
passionate he was always campaigning and
he ran a Chinese clinic in South London
and he worked so hard to help patients
who came to him with chronic diseases or
sometimes with medically unexplained
symptoms and his method was to listen to
them and respect them and ask them to
switch off their devices at seven
o'clock in order to get restorative
sleep and he said the body heals itself
it was a very big believer in human
rights and respecting patients and
that's why it was so difficult for us
when he became unwell at the beginning
of March and to see this
larger-than-life character who was
always the center attention the loudest
in the room full of positivity to see
him lying down weak unable to move and
yet he refused to go to hospital he said
people are going to hospital die he said
I don't want to die alone and he even
though his body was increasingly weak he
he knew his mind he was clear and we had
to respect him and that was really
difficult because we just thought if you
go into a hospital you get some fluids I
guess my oxygen that will help you and
now will help you recover
and he stayed at home for days and days
and he eventually collapsed and I was
actually three weeks ago today it was
the first clap for our carers and I
remember being out in the street in
Sheffield and it was such an emotional
moment we're all connected with the
neighbors and two hours later my father
finally collapsed at home and agreed to
allow an ambulance to take him to
hospital
Louise so sorry Alex sorry Sebastian I'm
so sorry to interrupt sir tell us then
what happened next he he had collapsed
and at that clap for Kira's having been
reticent about going into hospital and
then ultimately the hand was forced from
that point onwards what was your view
his view of the treatment and and the
eventual outcomes we were filled with
some hope we were given great
compassionate care at st. George's
Hospital they spend a lot of time
talking with us and explaining things
they were patient and we can't fault
that at all we were so delighted they
really took the time and I know that
they're so busy and drugged he didn't
like the face mask he said it was
putting pressure on his face as really
loud or the option he needed maximum
oxygen and he kept complaining he said
he couldn't be comfortable he said this
is inhumane I don't want to go on like
this
I have human rights I have the right to
choose whether I live or die I have the
right to choose whether to go home or
stay and this was so difficult to listen
to and we had to respect it and so we
chose to make a family video call to
discuss this to discuss his potential
end of life and on that call what's that
video called was his wife Melina and who
my two sisters Chingy and Alicia and I
led it and really listened to him and
started where he was at
to understand what he wanted because
even though I felt if he stayed there he
would have a good chance of living and
get home and be strong again and he said
he wanted to go home I said you have to
be a hundred percent sure you can't be
92 percent 88 century you need to be a
hundred percent sure and he hesitated
and actually he decided at that moment
he wasn't 100 percent ready and so I
said what would you like to do in the
next day or two and he thought for a
moment and he said what he would like to
do is complete his book he's compiling a
book of testimonials from his Chinese
clinic and he has helped so many
patients and they have written such
positive feedback and he wanted to put
that together as a service to spread the
world spread the word about what is
possible so that seems to matter I
suggest I wonder if you can tell us
because we I don't want us to run out of
time but one of the key things in all of
this having heard from the health
secretary yesterday about them
attempting to make it easier for loved
ones like yourself to see their families
at the end of their life how important
is you what happened was that coach and
then so the first weight at the end of
that phone call I suggested that he
could use the power of his mind to
overcome the inconvenience that the pain
and that would make an epic final
chapter for his book and that really
inspired him and in that moment we were
so close and so connected and so real so
it was the probably the closest we had
ever been and he said he loved me and I
said I loved him and we meant it and we
were really together and so the first
message is actually you can be totally
present and totally together and it is
so powerful through a video call we
don't have to be physically in the same
room so that was the first thing so I
think everybody should be allowed this
possibility of video cause boosting
Wi-Fi giving devices and supporting it
because one of the problems we had is
when we tried to make a call the next
day which was his final day
he slept most of the day and then when
he woke up he didn't know his PIN number
and couldn't unlock his phone so the
nurses had to call us twice and then
when we finally got there those Apes and
let left on his phone so there's that we
were very fortunate because after the
final video call with Singapore which
was again very powerful and he actually
said I'm a hundred percent ready to go
home now that really meant so much
because thang brought a lot of closure
he was ready so that even though I
wasn't present myself at the end that
brought a lot of closure for me he died
two hours later just want to emphasize
that actually because the family had
been in the building for that final
video call the nurses kindly let his
wife and my two sisters into the room
for those final few seconds and actually
being present together for those final
seconds meant everything to them and I'm
so grateful that Hancock has actually
said the family should and can be
allowed to be together
at those final moments but video calls
and harnessing that technology which is
very very simple and boosting Wi-Fi to
enable a strong signal there are a
number of simple things that we can all
do and what Sebastian and our
condolences to you on the loss of a man
who sounds quite incredible frankly and
very very briefly because we are just
about to run out of time if you had a
message for the staff at George's at
hospital I know well they very Abele
treated mine very young very ill son not
that long ago if you had a message for
the members of staff at Georgie's who
looked after your father what would it
be I really want to clap for our carers
all across the country both us and
George's and in care homes across the
NHS I'm so grateful your compassion
meant so much to us and such a terribly
difficult time so thank you very much
proud
you Sebastian um we just lost you at the
end there but I think we've got we got
everything we need thank you so much and
again our condolences on the loss of
your father thank you very much